we're going to use this as a scaffold to
develop a couple of really neat formulas
so I did this so that you wouldn't have
to waste so much time drawing circles
with pairs of compasses your circles are
ready-made what we're gonna think about
is these two things on the right hand
side arc length and sector area I click
at sector area so we're gonna figure out
these things one at a time here near a
cool take that is yes all right here's
all I going to start with I want us to
think of this as a general circle a
circle of any size so we don't know what
it's radius is okay now what I'm gonna
do is if we say forget the right thing
you if I say an angle of 2 pi if we said
an angle of 2 pi in the circle that's
how much of a revolution japon that's
the whole revolution isn't it so in
other words I get the whole circle and I
get an arc that goes all the way around
you can fill this here that's why I've
made it dotted there for you an arc that
goes all the way around the circle
because 2 pi is a full revolution ok now
this particular arc length because it
goes all the way around we have a name
for this right starts with a c when
you're all the way around the circle
it's called the circumference very good
on a circle of any size what is the
length of the circumference
what's our formula for it 2 pi r very
good 2 pi ah there's just hold that
thought
all that thought now this sector that
we're interested in in this case with 2
pi it's just the whole circle isn't it
right because I'm doing an angle of 2 pi
so what's the area of a circle pi
r-squared thank you very much actually
I'm just going to add on to that the arc
length since we're working on a lake
we'll call it L and because this is an
area we'll just call it a ok very good
so that's 2 pi nothing too dramatic
all right let's have a smaller angle
here let's go 3 pi odd - so in degrees
that would be 270 degrees very good so
you'll need to mark in the center here
right and my angle of 270 degrees you
can draw a couple different ways I'm
gonna
yes so my angle is going to go around
around like so so the arc that goes with
this is going to go around the circle
this look that's not a very good oxide
let's try it again this is so much
easier on the whiteboard but I wanted to
do this for your accuracy saying okay so
there's my arc and it goes all this way
around the circle as you can see now I'm
not getting the whole circumference am i
how much of this circumference said I
get 3/4 right 3/4 so that whole
circumference 2 PI R I would multiply
that by three quarters by three fourths
three over four can you guys simplify
that for me yep PI R times three over
two I might put that three over two out
the front and then there's the PI
then there's the R huh interesting
okay one more let's go over to the area
I'm not getting the whole area of the
circle I'm only getting again three
quarters right so I guess I would write
that as 3/4 times PI R squared you're ok
with that
all right you're starting to get a hang
of this right can you for the next two
circles can you do pi radians get the
according arc length and its area and
then for this fourth one do PI on two
for me can you do those and give you a
minute to catch up ok so catch me up
we were looking at PI and PI on to what
was the arc length you got 4 pi it's
just PI off just play our yep you get
ahead yourself ok the area of this
semicircle of course is yep PI R squared
over 2 or 1/2 PI R squared is also fine
and then for this guy here which we
would call when you've got a quarter of
a circle does anyone know it's got a
special name just like half a circle is
a semicircle it's called a quadrant when
you got a quarter of a circle a quadrant
so the arc length you get for this
quadrant is yep half of Pi ah
and then our area lastly is 1/4 PI R
squared ok now what I want us to have a
look at is these four rows and
want us to try and observe the pattern
that is here there's a couple actually
at least for example let's just think
about arc length for a second when you
look at the angle that you start with
and then you look over at the arc length
that results okay firstly you always get
are there why do you always get are my
side always there you gotta have the
radius it's like I don't know how big
this circle is so you have to tell me
how big the circle is obviously the
bigger the circle the bigger the arc
right but then you've got alongside that
are every time you have this guy right
and what does that happen to equal that
angle out the front of the arc length
seven of all your guesses sorry that was
a pretty impressive one because it's
literally not a single 705 page what's
the relationship between that
coefficient of R and the angle isn't it
exactly this yeah yeah the angle decides
how long your arc like this in fact if
we had here's your last circle down the
bottom right if you had an arc formed by
some random angle let's just put some
weirdo looking angle here right suppose
you had an angle of say let's call it
theta right and I thought well how long
will the arc be if I have not a nicely
angle like to PI or PI or something like
that if you have theta radians
right yeah go ahead if you had feet
Iranians right then the length of the
arc
well like you told me you've got to have
the radius because it depends on how big
the circle is and then what do you
multiply it by what did we do it in all
the subsequent instead of like pile on
to pile on to going here and then pound
to you're going here it's like the
angles not planets we the angles you
know so you just multiply by that angle
right if you want to work out the length
of an arc you need to know how big the
circle is and then you just multiply by
the angle that you form okay now just
before we go into area I just want you
to model a how wonderfully simple that
formula is it's like oh it's thinking
like the area of a rectangle that's
housed in
for it is because radians are built to
be used with circles okay when you're
doing this in degrees you've got to do
awkward conversions and that kind of
thing whereas radians I clearly fit for
purpose okay all right now when we come
over to area this one takes its slight
bit more thought but not that much
do you notice again I'll highlight in a
different color you also have an angle
at the front and then instead of our
you've got r-squared why is it R squared
there there are two hours why they're
two hours why we're doing R times R yeah
I was always there it's never getting
care to anything but it's yes it's it's
like a square because we're thinking
about area
aren't we area is a two dimensional
quantity length is our one dimensional
quantity so that's why there's a single
arc here and there's our times R over
here so the R squared is in common every
time but the angle doesn't quite match
up does it with the angle we get over
here it's not exactly the same what is
it it's always half of what angle you
started with right so in fact we could
write PI R squared we could write it as
half R squared times 2 pi do you agree
with that I mean I know it looks a
little awkward because you're like why
would you not just cancel on behalf of
the two but the reason I write it this
way is now I just have a look at the
next one it's 1/2 R squared times what 3
pi onto the angle that we started with
right this one's already sort of written
in this form right it's half R squared
and then what's the angle on the end
it's just PI right and then our last one
here is 1/2 R squared and then what's
the angle PI on 2 and that's why the the
two twos become that quarter that you
got so if I were to generalize this and
say there's a formula we're always
getting 1/2 and then R squared and then
what's the thing we multiply for an
angle of theta just just theta right
I've got that on to at the front you see
out with the 1/2 so this guy here this
is our formula for the area of a sector
according to whatever angle that you
have said
tended at the center okay so what you've
got here this pair of equations they're
what we call the UM bless you the
circular measure form is because
surprise surprise they help you measure
circles okay so we can use these in a
variety of ways
if you turn you're gonna need to open up
your year eleven textbook and 14b is
where we're going to be looking you can
see all these shapes that are variations
on bless you
arcs and n sectors right now I should
point out and I didn't do it on the on
the piece of paper but will quickly show
you it's so much easier to do it on a
whiteboard if you have a look at this
slice of pie that I've just cut out what
did we call that again starts with an S
this shape here this is a sector thank
you very much but if what I do instead
of taking this whole slice of pie or
this whole pizza slice if what I do is
instead cut off an edge part like that
see this guy here that guy there it's
not a sector anymore does anyone know
the special name for this little tiny
sliver it's called a segment very good
now the area of a segment think about
this fourteen bit the area segment is
it's the sector you started with right
which is what did we establish was the
area of a sector half ass squared theta
1/2 R squared fear that's the whole
sector but then what you want to remove
is this triangular bit you see that this
guy here okay we're getting rid of that
it's a triangle how would we work at the
area of this triangle
keeping in mind we know this angle it's
theta and we also know these two sides
so in a way we can work this out nice
and simply
think about this we have two sides at an
angle we have a formula for this right
it's a take away huh a b-side see what's
how al B in this case they're both the
radius right so instead of saying a B
I'm gonna write R times R which is R
squared and then you say sine C what's
the included angle here it's the only
the only angle I've got there sine theta
so marvelously you get this simple
cancelling or carefully is not the right
word factorization right what's in
common between these two terms bar
squared theta
sorry half R squared and then inside the
brackets you're going to get the feed of
motifs sine theta please please please
note right that's nice isn't it please
note this is all the ingredients right
you pop this into your calculator in
degrees and you get a whole different
thing don't you
so all of these four B's we've developed
this one for the segment this one for
the sector and then the length of an arc
they all require you to be in radians
when you're calculating and when you're
measuring angles make sense